Tyra: LOTS OF GIRLS
GROW UP WANTING TO BE MODELS
BECAUSE THEY THINK
IT'S GLAMOROUS, EXCITING,
AND, YOU KNOW, FUN.
WRONG!
- Catie: (cries)
- Jenascia: THOSE BITCHES!
Tyra: "AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL" HAS TAKEN
THIS GROUP OF GIRLS
ON QUITE A JOURNEY.
THEY'VE POSED NUDE,
THEY'VE GOTTEN
DRASTIC MAKEOVERS
AND THEY'VE DONE SOME REALLY
DIFFICULT PHOTO SHOOTS
THAT HAVE PUSHED THEM
TO THEIR LIMITS.
FIND OUT HOW THIS GROUP OF 12
GOT DOWN TO THE FINAL FOUR.
IT ALL BEGINS NOW WITH MOMENTS
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE,
INCLUDING THE WILDEST PRANK...
(laughter)
Tyra: THE MOST
EMBARRASSING MOMENTS...
Janice: WHAT THE HELL
WAS THAT?
Tyra: AND WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THE JUDGES TURN
ON EACH OTHER.
Jay: WE'RE TALKING
SILICONE VALLEY
AT THE OTHER END OF THE TABLE.
Janice: OH, STAND UP.
LET'S SEE THE GIRDLE
YOU'RE WEARING.
Jay: JANICE, YOURS IS ALREADY
SURGICALLY CINCHED.
I SNAP ONE THREAD,
AND IT'S DOWN.
♪♪♪
Tyra: FOR THE SECOND SEASON
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
WE HAD THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF APPLICANTS.
THIS TIME WE CHOSE 12.
Shandi: AND THE REASON
I WANT TO BE THE NEXT TOP MODEL
IS BECAUSE I AM TIRED OF WORKING
AT WALGREENS.
Mercedes: MY FLAVOR
WOULD BE THAT I'M SASSY.
Heather: I JUST TURNED 18
THREE DAYS AGO.
Jenascia: WHEN I SHOWER,
I LIKE TO PLAY SOME HOOPS.
THE BALL'S OVER HERE SOMEWHERE.
Anna: SAY, "WE'RE GOING
TO THE OTHER ROOM."
Makarious: (babbling)
WE GO OTHER ROOM.
Anna: OKAY.
Xiomara: PLEASE, CALL ME XIOMI.
DON'T CALL ME XIOMARA.
IT'S JUST TOO HARD,
UNLESS YOU CAN REALLY SAY IT
AND ROLL YOUR R's--
(rolling R's) XIOMARA.
Bethany: I WAS BORN HERE
IN HOUSTON.
YEE-HA! WHA-WHA-WHA!
Yoanna: WE DON'T REALLY HAVE
A GREAT DEPARTMENT STORE
HERE IN JACKSONVILLE,
WHICH IS REALLY DEPRESSING.
Catie: I KNOW WHAT MAKES ME
DIFFERENT IS I HATE MODELS.
Camille: THERE COMES A TIME
WHEN PEOPLE GET ON YOUR NERVES,
AND THEY BOTHER YOU,
AND THEY KIND OF ANNOY YOU.
April: I'M A FIGHTER
TO THE DEATH.
LET THE GAMES BEGIN.
Sara: I HAVE WHAT IT TAKES,
OF COURSE.
Anna: COULD YOU TELL ME
WHERE BROAD STREET IS?
Tyra: AFTER BRINGING
THE GIRLS FROM ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY TO NEW YORK CITY,
I'VE DECIDED TO DO SOMETHING
TOTALLY DIFFERENT THIS YEAR.
I JUST WANTED TO SHAKE IT UP
AND SHOCK THE GIRLS.
I'M NOT WASTING ANY TIME.
I'M THROWING YOU
STRAIGHT ON A RUNWAY.
YOU'RE GONNA BE DOING IT
IN FRONT OF THE BEST
OF NEW YORK--
OUR FIREFIGHTERS
AND OUR MILITARY.
Jenascia: ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
J.: OKAY, GIRLS,
YOU HAVE EXACTLY 30 MINUTES
TO GET READY.
YOU EACH WILL BE WEARING
THREE OUTFITS.
IT'S CRITICAL
THAT YOU REMEMBER YOUR ORDER.
REMEMBER, FOLLOW THE HAIR
AND MAKEUP INSTRUCTIONS.
Anna: I FEEL LIKE
THE ROADRUNNER RIGHT NOW.
I'M TRYING TO BE VERY FAST.
Sara: I'M EXCITED.
Catie: I USUALLY
LIKE SURPRISES,
BUT THIS IS
TO A DIFFERENT MAGNITUDE.
J.: PRESSURE IS ON!
Tyra: APRIL GOT CAUGHT UP
IN THE CHAOS AND LOST CONTROL.
April: I HAVE
THE WRONG OUTFIT ON.
Jenascia: ALL OF A SUDDEN
I SAW THAT APRIL--
SHE HAD HER SECOND OUTFIT
ON FIRST.
April: AND I START
TO CRY IMMEDIATELY,
BECAUSE I AM SO STRESSED
THAT I MANAGED TO SCREW UP
WITHIN THE FIRST TEN MINUTES
OF THIS COMPETITION.
Jenascia: HERE, I'LL DO THAT.
YOU DO THIS.
April: THE ONLY THING
THAT IS LITERALLY KEEPING
MY KNEES FROM COLLAPSING
ON ME RIGHT NOW IS THE FACT
THAT JENASCIA IS AT MY SIDE.
I'M THINKING, "I OWE HER."
Jenascia: I'M NOT REALLY
THAT NICE OF A PERSON.
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S COME OVER ME.
♪♪♪
Tyra: THAT RUNWAY SHOW
EXPOSED THEM AS AMATEURS,
AND IT SHOWED JUST HOW FAR
THEY HAD TO GO.
J.: OKAY, GIRLS,
PERSONALLY, I THINK
YOU ALL SUCKED, ACTUALLY.
Tyra: THE NEXT MORNING,
THE GIRLS WOKE UP SUPER EARLY
FOR THEIR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT,
BUT JENASCIA WAS SOUND ASLEEP,
AND APRIL WAS TORN
ABOUT WHAT TO DO.
April: IF I RUN UPSTAIRS,
ARE YOU GUYS GONNA MAKE SURE
THEY DON'T LEAVE WITHOUT ME
OR NO?
PROBABLY NOT, RIGHT?
Anna: RUN UP INSIDE AND SEE.
April: I AM NOT ABLE
TO HELP HER OUT
AND GET HER IN THAT VAN
WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING
EVERY SINGLE OTHER PERSON'S
ABILITY TO GET TO THE SHOOT.
SHE HELPED ME OUT ON THE RUNWAY,
AND THAT'S TEARING ME UP INSIDE.
Tyra: THE MODELS HAD NO IDEA
WHAT TYPE OF SHOOT
THEY WERE IN FOR.
Ed: THIS IS THE MAJOR PART
OF YOUR COSTUME RIGHT HERE.
YOUR BODY'S GONNA BE COVERED
IN JEWELS AND BODY PAINT.
Anna: SO OUR WHOLE BODY'S
COVERED IN THE PAINT?
Ed: YEAH, YOUR BODIES
WILL BE COVERED IN PAINT, YES.
Nigel: YES, BUT, I MEAN,
OBVIOUSLY YOU ARE GONNA BE NUDE.
Tyra: ANNA, A WIFE
AND MOTHER, WAS SHOCKED.
Nigel: I SEE WE ONLY HAVE 11.
Tyra: AND JENASCIA
WAS STILL ASLEEP.
Nigel: WELL, WE'LL HAVE
TO GET A WAKE-UP CALL INTO HER.
(telephone rings)
(sighs)
- Jenascia: HELLO?
- Jim: IS THIS JENASCIA?
Jenascia: I DON'T KNOW
HOW THIS HAPPENED!
Jim: SO GET YOURSELF TOGETHER
AND GET HERE ASAP.
Jenascia: THOSE
(bleep) BITCHES!
THEY LET ME JUST SLEEP.
I DON'T KNOW.
THEY MUST HAVE TIPPED AROUND
LIKE... MICE THIS MORNING,
'CAUSE I DIDN'T HEAR
A DAMN THING.
I WAS SO NAIVE TO THINK THAT
THE OTHER GIRLS WERE ACTUALLY
GONNA HELP ME OUT,
EVEN THOUGH I HAD HELPED
SOME OF THEM OUT.
- Camille: FOCUS ON...
- Jenascia: ME.
Camille: YEAH,
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO RIGHT NOW
IS GET THE BEST PICTURES.
Jenascia: I JUST DIDN'T KNOW
THAT SOME PEOPLE WERE
THAT THREATENED BY ME.
BITCHES!
Catie: MY DAD--
I DON'T THINK HE WAS COMFORTABLE
WITH ME DOING NUDE.
YOU KNOW, IF I'M DOING NUDE,
AT LEAST I'M BEING AN ANGEL.
Sara: GRANDMA, DON'T HATE ME!
♪♪♪
Tyra: WHILE JENASCIA WAS
PREPPING FOR HER PHOTO SHOOT,
ANNA WAS HAVING A MORAL CRISIS.
Anna: I SAT THERE IN THE ROOM,
AND I SAW THESE GIRLS.
THEIR BREASTS WERE HANGING OUT
AND NIPPLES SHOWING.
I CAN'T JUST IMAGINE
SOMEONE ELSE HERE AND DOWN THERE
EXCEPT MY HUSBAND, YOU KNOW?
AND IF I SHOW IT
TO THE WHOLE WORLD, YOU KNOW,
WHAT'S SO SPECIAL WHEN I...
(crying)
I JUST CAN'T.
I CANNOT DO IT.
Tyra: WHEN IT CAME
TO THE FIRST ELIMINATION,
THE TWO GIRLS IN JEOPARDY
WERE ANNA AND JENASCIA.
Tyra: LET'S DISCUSS ANNA.
I LOVE A PLUS-SIZE GIRL.
SHE HAS A BEAUTIFUL
PLUS-SIZE FIGURE.
Eric: HER RUNWAY
DEFINITELY NEEDED SOME WORK.
Jenascia: HER REFUSAL
TO DO THE SESSION
DIDN'T WORK FOR ME.
Tyra: JUST BECAUSE
SHE DID NOT DO THE SHOOT,
DOESN'T MEAN THAT
SHE'S AUTOMATICALLY ELIMINATED.
Nigel: IN FACT,
THE GIRL THAT WAS LATE
WAS MORE DAMAGING FOR ME.
Tyra: BUT IN THE END,
IT WAS ANNA WHO WAS SENT HOME.
THANK YOU, ANNA.
Anna: THANK YOU, TYRA.
YOU KNOW, I CAME HERE
TO PURSUE MODELING
AND BE PASSIONATE ABOUT IT,
AND IT'S A TALENT
THAT I NEED TO EXPRESS.
I'M NOT GONNA STOP HERE.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER OBSTACLE
I'M GONNA OVERCOME.
Women: WHOO!
Tyra: AFTER THE FIRST CUT,
IT WAS TIME TO REINTRODUCE
THE GIRLS TO J. ALEXANDER.
J.: OKAY,
SO I'M GONNA HAVE YOU WALK.
GIRL, DO YOUR THING.
Tyra: ON THE RUNWAY,
THE GIRLS HAD DIFFERENT
STRENGTHS AND WEAKNESSES.
J.: AH, AH, AH!
BRAVO!
GET UP. KEEP ON WALKING, BABY.
Tyra: BETHANY TRIED
TO WORK HER CURVES.
Bethany: OBVIOUSLY
I KNOW THAT I DON'T HAVE
A STICK-THIN FIGURE,
BUT QUITE HONESTLY,
NEITHER DOES HALF OF AMERICA.
Tyra: SHANDI WAS
INCREDIBLY AWKWARD.
J.: HELP.
♪♪♪
Tyra: CAMILLE WAS CONFIDENT.
J.: OH, SEE, I...
SEE, YOU KNOW,
BLACK GIRLS ALWAYS HAVE
TO GIVE THAT EXTRA.
Tyra: AND YOANNA LOOKED
LIKE THE WALKING DEAD.
J.: YOUR WALK IS REALLY--
IT'S AS USELESS AS A FLASHLIGHT
WITH NO BATTERIES IN THE DARK.
Camille: (laughs)
Tyra: AND AFTER
THE RUNWAY LESSON,
TENSIONS EXPLODED
BETWEEN CAMILLE AND YOANNA.
Camille: FOR REAL,
IF I HAVE SOMETHING
TO SAY TO YOU,
I WILL SAY IT TO YOUR FACE.
Yoanna: THE LAST COUPLE TIMES
THAT YOU'VE HAD THINGS TO SAY
ABOUT ME, YOU'VE NEVER SAID IT
TO MY FACE, AND WHEN
I'VE CONFRONTED YOU ABOUT IT--
Camille: I HAVEN'T SAID
ANYTHING TO YOU--
Yoanna: OKAY, OKAY, ENJOY.
Camille: AND TRUST ME, IF I HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY TO YOU--
Yoanna: I DON'T TRUST YOU!
Camille: I WILL SAY IT
TO YOUR FACE.
- Yoanna: I DO NOT TRUST YOU.
- Camille: WELL, THAT'S MY WORD.
IF YOU DON'T TRUST ME,
STAY AWAY FROM ME.
Tyra: AND THOSE TENSIONS
CARRIED OVER
TO A HOUSE MEETING.
Yoanna: IT IS GETTING
TO THE POINT WHERE IT IS
SO NEGATIVE IN THIS HOUSE,
THE ENERGY IS DRIVING ME CRAZY.
IT'S LIKE WE HAVE TO OPEN
THE WINDOWS AND LET--
JUST, WAIT! I'M NOT FINISHED!
Camille: WHERE DOES THAT HATE
AND THE ANGER COME FROM?
I WANT TO KNOW
WHERE THAT ANGER COMES FROM,
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE THAT ANGER
INSIDE OF ME FOR ANYONE.
I SAID, "IF I HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY TO YOU,
I'LL SAY IT TO YOUR FACE,"
AND THAT WAS THAT.
OTHER THAN THAT, I'M SAYING
STAY... OUT OF MY WAY.
Tyra: BETHANY HAD
SOME OF HER OWN CONCERNS,
WHICH SHE CONFIDED TO ME
THAT NIGHT.
Bethany: I WANT SOMETHING
TO WORK ON.
I CAN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT MY CHEST.
Tyra: YES, YOU CAN.
YOU CAN POSE DIFFERENTLY.
YOU'RE NOT THE ONLY MODEL
THAT HAS A BIG CHEST.
Bethany: IF Y'ALL CAN'T STOP
LOOKING AT MY BOOBS
AND START LOOKING AT THE TALENT,
IT'S LIKE, I'M NOT GONNA
SIT HERE AND BE CRITICIZED
OF THE SAME THING.
Tyra: I SUGGEST
YOU LAY OFF THE ATTITUDE.
IT'S NOT NECESSARY,
I'M HERE TO HELP YOU.
I BELIEVE IN EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU,
BUT EVERYBODY HAS A FLAW,
AND EVERYBODY NEEDS
TO WORK ON THAT.
AND THAT'S YOUR JOB.
NO MODEL IS PERFECT.
YOU LEARN.
THEN IT WAS ON
TO THE SECOND PHOTO SHOOT,
WHERE THE GIRLS HAD
TO STYLE THEMSELVES.
Jay: SO JUST TAKE A STEP
ON THE STAGE.
Tyra: BETHANY DID HER BEST
TO CONCEAL HER... ASSETS.
Bethany: OKAY,
TYRA SAID BE CAREFUL
ABOUT POKING MY CHEST OUT.
AND IT'S ABOUT THE SHOES.
IT'S REALLY NOT ABOUT ME,
I GUESS.
Jay: YOU GOTTA
GIVE IT TO ME NOW.
Bethany: 55, I GUESS.
NO, 94, 94!
Tyra: IN THE END,
THE JUDGES DECIDED THAT BETHANY
WASN'T VERSATILE ENOUGH
FOR FASHION MODELING.
Bethany: I KNOW THAT
I HAVE A LOT MORE TALENT
THAN PROBABLY HALF
OF THESE GIRLS HERE.
IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING TO ME.
THIS IS SOMETHING
I REALLY WANTED.
JUST LEAVE ME... ALONE.
(crying)
♪♪♪
Tyra: STILL TO COME--
APRIL FREAKS OUT.
April: THEY CAN'T
SNEAK UP ON ME.
Tyra: WE SEE
A WHOLE NEW SIDE OF HEATHER.
(laughter)
Tyra: AND IT'S JAY
VERSUS JANICE.
Jay: SHE LOOKS
LIKE A PORNO STAR.
Janice: SO DO YOU.
Tyra: I FELT THAT
A LOT OF THE GIRLS
NEEDED A DRASTIC MAKEOVER.
SO I SENT THEM TO THE SALON
FOR A MAJOR OVERHAUL.
DO YOU LIKE YOUR CUT?
Yoanna: YES, I LOVE IT.
I REALLY DO.
OH, IT'S PRETTY!
IT'S LIGHT AND PRETTY!
Mercedes: I LIKE MY LOOK.
IT'S VIBRANT, IT'S SEXY,
IT'S EDGY.
- Xiomara: I LOVE IT.
- Shandi: WHOO!
Xiomara: I LOVE IT!
Shandi: EVERYTHING'S
COME TOGETHER,
AND I FEEL SO PRETTY RIGHT NOW.
Tyra: BUT CATIE
WASN'T SO HAPPY.
Catie: I LOOK LIKE A BOY!
Tyra: BUT THAT'S GORGEOUS!
DO YOU KNOW THAT A MODEL
THAT HAS SHORT HAIR
AND CAN PULL OFF SHORT HAIR,
MEANS SHE'S TRULY BEAUTIFUL.
AND THAT WHEN YOU'RE HIDING
BEHIND HAIR,
IT MEANS YOU'RE JUST COMMON
AND HIDING BEHIND HAIR.
THIS IS GORGEOUS!
WAIT TILL YOU HAVE
YOUR MAKEUP DONE!
RIGHT NOW, YEAH,
IT'S A LITTLE OLIVER TWIST,
BUT WHEN THEY STYLE IT
AND YOU GET YOUR MAKEUP DONE,
IT'S GONNA BE SO PRETTY.
BUT YOU'RE NOT GONNA
LOOK LIKE A BOY, GIRL.
YOU'VE GOT BOOTY.
YOU'RE GONNA WORK IT OUT.
Catie: (crying)
Tyra: HEATHER, LIKE CATIE,
WAS ALSO 18 AND HAD A LOT
OF CRYING EPISODES,
BUT LITTLE DID WE KNOW,
SHE HAD A LITTLE FREAK
IN HER, TOO.
Heather: (burps)
Catie: WHY IS YOUR SEAT WET?
Heather: 'CAUSE I PEED.
Sara: I DARE YOU...
I'LL GIVE YOU...
I SWEAR TO GOD,
I'LL GIVE YOU $5 IF YOU DO IT.
I WAS JUST LIKE,
"I'D BET YOU $5
THAT YOU WON'T RUN AROUND
THIS HOUSE BUTT NAKED."
♪♪♪
Heather: AAH!
(laughter)
Tyra: THEN A TYRA MAIL CAME.
- Xiomara: "VENUSTRAPHOBIA...
- Camille: "VENUSTRAPHOBIA...
Both: "THE FEAR
OF BEAUTIFUL WOMEN.
"OPHIDIOPHOBIA--
THE FEAR OF SNAKES.
"ALGOPHOBIA--THE FEAR OF PAIN.
WHAT ARE YOU AFRAID OF?
WE'LL FIND OUT TOMORROW."
Tyra: AND APRIL WENT
INTO A PANIC WHEN SHE THOUGHT
THERE WOULD BE SNAKES
AT THE SHOOT.
April: I'M GOING
HOME TOMORROW.
I CAN'T EVEN SAY
THE NAME OF THIS STUFF.
- I'M GOING HOME.
- Catie: WHAT ARE YOU SCARED OF?
April: WHAT THEY PUT
ON THAT PAPER.
Jenascia: LOOK AT ME,
LOOK AT ME, HEY, FOCUS!
LOOK AT ME. COME ON.
April: (wailing)
Jenascia: I PROMISE
I'M RIGHT HERE.
Sara: IT'S OKAY.
April: IT'S IN HERE,
IT'S IN HERE, IT'S IN HERE!
Sara: NO, IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT, IT'S NOT.
IT'S FIRE, IT'S FIRE, OKAY?
- April: IT'S FIRE?
- Sara: IT'S FIRE.
LOOK AT THE SMOKE.
April: I NEED TO KNOW
WHERE THEY ARE.
THEY CAN'T SNEAK UP ON ME.
Sara: THEY WON'T
SNEAK UP ON YOU.
THERE'S NOTHING HERE.
Jay: GOOD MORNING, GIRLS.
WE ARE GOING TO SUSPEND YOU
FROM THIS LEDGE
AND SHOOT YOU GUYS
HANGING OVER THIS HOLE.
Tyra: APRIL BREATHED
A SIGH OF RELIEF,
BUT CATIE'S FEAR OF HEIGHTS
KICKED INTO HIGH GEAR.
Catie: I'M SCARED
OF HEIGHTS, DAD.
I WISH YOU COULD BE HERE.
(crying)
Tyra: THE REST OF THE GIRLS
JUMPED RIGHT IN.
Jay: CAN WE BRING HER UP
A LITTLE HIGHER?
♪♪♪
Tyra: HEATHER SHOWED GUTS,
BUT SHE COULDN'T QUITE
NAIL THE POSE.
Jay: GREAT, GIVE ME
THE INTENSITY EYE,
BUT CLOSE YOUR MOUTH.
YEAH, NOW CLOSE YOUR MOUTH.
IT LOOKS GREAT,
AND JUST KEEP YOUR MOUTH CLOSED
THE WHOLE TIME.
CLOSE THE MOUTH.
Tyra: XIOMARA GAVE CATIE
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT.
Xiomara: DO YOU WANT ME
TO GO BEFORE YOU, CATIE?
IT'S ALL GOOD, IT'S ALL GOOD.
IT'S CAKE, BABY.
Tyra: AND FINALLY CATIE
GOT INTO THE HARNESS...
Jay: ALL RIGHT,
JUST LOOK AT ME RIGHT HERE.
THAT'S IT, THAT'S IT.
IT'S OKAY.
DO YOU WANT TO COME UP, CATIE?
- Catie: GIVE ME A SECOND.
- Jay: OKAY.
Tyra: AND MOMENTARILY
MASTERED HER FEAR.
Jay: NO ONE ELSE TALK,
JUST ME.
OKAY, BEAUTIFUL. I LOVE IT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT, CATIE?
YOU GOT IT.
YOU'RE DONE.
YOU ARE SO DONE.
(cheers and applause)
Tyra: AT JUDGING, XIOMARA'S
ACT OF KINDNESS BACKFIRED.
Eric: THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT JUST ISN'T CONNECTING.
IT JUST LOOKS SLOPPY.
Xiomara: I DIDN'T REALLY
HAVE MUCH DIRECTION
IN ALL DUE HONESTY
AND FAIRNESS TO YOU,
BECAUSE HE WAS COMFORTING CATIE.
I WAS OUT THERE BY MYSELF.
Catie: I HAVE A LITTLE WORD
TO SAY.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
YOU REALIZE, YES,
JAY WAS SITTING NEXT TO ME
FOR MOST OF THE PART.
THE ENTIRE TIME
HE NEVER SAID A WORD TO ME.
HE WAS DIRECTING XIOMARA.
Xiomara: HE WAS DIRECTING ME,
BUT HE WAS ALSO COMFORTING YOU,
AS WELL.
IT WAS REALLY CONFUSING.
IT WAS REALLY WEIRD.
THE ENERGY WAS...
AND I WAS COMFORTING YOU
WHEN YOU WERE GOING UP, TOO,
AND YOU KNOW THAT,
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I SAID TO YOU.
Janice: BOARDING SCHOOL,
BOARDING SCHOOL.
I DON'T CARE
WHAT YOU GUYS DID ON THE SET.
OH, MY GOD.
DRAMA, DRAMA.
Tyra: THE TENSION
CONTINUED BACKSTAGE.
Camille: CAN WE GET
SOME WATER?
April: WE NEED A FAN
OR SOMETHING.
Yoanna: HERE, COME OUT
IN THE FRESH AIR.
April: YOU NEED A FAN
OR SOMETHING?
Yoanna: AFTER THE JUDGING,
CATIE JUST KIND OF GOT
WEAK AND FAINT.
Sara: THERE WAS
THIS BIG PRODUCTION WITH HER
GETTING FANNED AND WATER,
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS HILARIOUS.
Tyra: IT WASN'T ONLY
THE GIRLS WHO GOT INTO IT.
SOMETIMES THE JUDGES HAD,
WELL, A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION.
Jay: I HAD TO FIGHT
WITH HEATHER ON THIS SHOOT
JUST TO GET
HER FACIAL EXPRESSION
TO LOOK SOMEWHAT LIKE A MODEL.
SHE LOOKS LIKE A PORNO STAR.
Janice: NO, SHE DOES NOT!
- Jay: YES, SHE DOES.
- Janice: SO DO YOU.
Jay: WE'RE TALKING
SILICONE VALLEY
- AT THE OTHER END OF THE TABLE.
- Janice: WELL, STAND UP!
LET'S SEE THE GIRDLE
YOU'RE WEARING.
Jay: JANICE, YOURS IS ALREADY
SURGICALLY CINCHED.
I SNAP ONE THREAD,
AND IT'S DOWN.
Janice: HONEY,
LOOK AT YOUR FACE, PLEASE,
AND YOUR DYED HAIR, PLEASE.
Jay: OKAY.
Tyra: THINGS COOLED OFF
WHEN CATIE AND XIOMARA
TALKED IT OUT
JUST BEFORE THE ELIMINATION.
Catie: YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK BECAUSE OF ME, THOUGH,
I FEEL LIKE NOBODY GOT 100%.
Xiomara: NO,
IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF YOU, CATIE.
IT'S JUST THAT JAY
DIDN'T GIVE ME ANYTHING.
THAT'S ALL.
IT'S OKAY, IT'S NOT YOU.
I WASN'T SAYING
ANYTHING ABOUT YOU.
Heather: BESIDES, CATIE,
IT WAS JAY'S DECISION
TO COMFORT YOU.
Catie: IF I WOULD HAVE
BEEN THINKING LOGICALLY,
I WOULD HAVE TOLD HIM,
"NO, SHE DESERVES MORE."
YOU KNOW THAT, RIGHT?
Xiomara: I KNOW, THAT'S OKAY.
I WASN'T TRYING TO, LIKE...
Catie: WHY ARE YOU CRYING?
Xiomara: BECAUSE YOU PASSED OUT.
- Camille: COME ON.
- Catie: I DID NOT!
Tyra: IN THE END,
HEATHER'S LIMITATIONS
OUTWEIGHED XIOMARA'S
AND HEATHER WAS SENT HOME.
Heather: THERE'S A LOT
MORE PEOPLE THAT DESERVE
TO GO HOME RATHER THAN ME.
I KNOW THAT
I'M PRETTIER THAN A LOT OF
THOSE GIRLS STANDING UP THERE,
AND THAT'S THE ONLY REASON
WHY IT WOULD EVER HURT.
(sniffling)
Tyra: SPENDING ALL THEIR TIME
TOGETHER INEVITABLY LED
TO PETTY ARGUMENTS.
Catie: OUR SINK WAS CLOGGED.
THEN OUR BATHROOM WAS CLOGGED.
Yoanna: WE WERE
SCRUBBING AND CLEANING,
AND CAMILLE WAS ON THE PHONE.
Catie: LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT MISS DIVA.
Camille: IF EVERYBODY
WANTS TO CLEAN IN A GROUP,
THEN COME LET ME KNOW
THAT YOU'RE CLEANING IN GROUPS,
SO THEN I CAN PARTICIPATE.
BUT LAST NIGHT, I GUESS
THAT BEFORE WHEN EVERYBODY
WAS IN THEIR BEDS SLEEPING,
I TOOK TWO HOURS OUT
OF MY SLEEP SCHEDULE TO CLEAN,
BECAUSE THE PLACE WAS DIRTY.
Catie: THOSE EXPLANATIONS
ARE ALWAYS INCREDIBLY,
INCREDIBLY LONG.
Camille: I DO CLEAN,
SO I DON'T WANT TO MAKE IT SEEM
LIKE, OH, I'M NOT PARTICIPATING
IN THE HOUSE BEING CLEAN,
'CAUSE I DO.
I JUST DO IT ALL BY MYSELF.
Catie: WELL, I'M SURE
YOU CAN LOOK AROUND
AND FIND SOMETHING
THAT YOU CAN CLEAN.
Camille: I MEAN,
THAT'S WHY I DID
WHAT I DID YESTERDAY.
Catie: UGH!
Tyra: THE GIRLS
GOT AN INVALUABLE LESSON
IN PERSONAL STYLE.
AND I HAVE MY BUDDY HERE,
MR. SIMON DOONAN.
SIMON IS THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
OF BARNEY'S NEW YORK.
Simon: IN ORDER FOR YOU GUYS
TO DEVELOP YOUR OWN STYLE,
WE HAVE TO PLAY
THE BRANDING GAME.
SEE ALL THESE WORDS?
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
ONE MINUTE TO GRAB THE WORDS
THAT PERTAIN TO YOU.
GO!
♪♪♪
- Sara: I PICKED EXOTIC.
- Simon: AS IN DANCER.
Shandi: I DON'T KNOW. I THINK
I KINDA HAVE A NERDY,
LITTLE GEEKY STYLE.
Mercedes: COQUETTISH,
'CAUSE I JUST LEARNED THE WORD.
Simon: WELL,
WHAT ARE THE THREE WORDS
THAT YOU WOULD DESCRIBE
AS WHAT YOU'RE WEARING TODAY?
Catie: I DON'T--
I REALLY DON'T KNOW.
I'M... I'VE ALWAYS--
Simon: WERE YOU HAVING A BREAK
WITH REALITY WHEN YOU GOT READY?
I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE
TOO MUCH HOOKER STYLE GOING ON
WITH THE LEG WARMERS
WITH THE HIGH HEELS.
GO DOWN WHERE THE HOOKERS
HANG OUT BY THE DOCKS
AND SEE WHAT THEY'RE WEARING,
AND THEN AVOID IT.
SOMETHING THAT
YOU GUYS HAVE TO BECOME
COMFORTABLE WITH--
BEING SELF-CRITICAL,
BEING CRITICAL OF EACH OTHER.
AND WHAT I GET
FROM SOME OF YOU GUYS
IS THAT YOU CAN'T YET DO THAT.
IN PARTICULAR YOU,
YOU SEEM TO BE GETTING
KIND OF IRATE, BECAUSE--
Catie: YOU CALLED ME A HO!
Simon: I WOULD NEVER
SAY ANYBODY WAS A HO.
I WOULD SAY, "THAT'S HO STYLE."
YOU HAVE TO GET USED TO THE FACT
THAT IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT YOU.
Catie: IF IT WAS YOU
AND ME TALKING, THAT'S COOL.
Simon: EXCEPT YOU KNEW
WHEN YOU ENTERED
INTO THIS COMPETITION
THAT YOU'RE NOT GONNA SIT THERE
FOR THREE WEEKS
WITH AN UMBRELLA DRINK
WITH EVERYBODY TELLING YOU
HOW FABULOUS YOU ARE.
Catie: NO, I DIDN'T EXPECT
THAT AT ALL, BUT I JUST--
Simon: BUT IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU DID.
Tyra: WHILE CATIE'S PROBLEMS
WERE OUT IN THE OPEN,
MERCEDES KEPT HERS INSIDE.
Mercedes: RECENTLY
AT THE HOUSE MY HAIR
HAS BEEN FALLING OUT
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH MEDICATION.
I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH LUPUS,
WHICH IS A CHRONIC ILLNESS
WHERE IT ATTACKS
YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM,
ABOUT A YEAR AGO,
AND IT PRETTY MUCH
CHANGED MY LIFE.
IT'S BEST TO KEEP IT A SECRET,
'CAUSE I DON'T WANT THEM
TO TALK ABOUT,
"OH, HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
OH, THIS MUST BE HARD."
YOU KNOW, DON'T GIVE ME THAT.
I DON'T NEED IT.
Tyra: WITH THE PHOTO SHOOT
COMING UP THE NEXT DAY,
MERCEDES' ANXIETY WAS HIGH.
- Mercedes' mom: Hello?
- Mercedes: HI, MOM.
HOW ARE YOU?
Mercedes' mom: You okay?
Mercedes: MY HAIR IS
CONTINUING TO FALL OUT...
LIKE, A LOT.
IT'S A LOT OF STRESS,
AND WHEN YOU HAVE LUPUS,
YOU CAN'T STRESS OUT,
AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO DO
IN THIS HOUSE,
BECAUSE IT'S VERY STRESSFUL.
PLEASE, TELL ME--
IT'S COMING OUT,
AND I'M SCARED.
Mercedes' mom: Okay.
Don't be scared, okay?
Mercedes: I'M JUST
TRYING TO JUST, LIKE, KEEP ON
PUSHING MYSELF, BECAUSE...
YOU KNOW, I'M JUST TRYING
TO STICK IN THERE.
Tyra: STILL TO COME--
THE COMPETITION GETS
VERY EMOTIONAL...
Yoanna: I WAS SO CHUBBY
AND FAT.
Tyra: AND JANICE ASKS
SOME TOUGH QUESTIONS.
Janice: IF A PHOTOGRAPHER
OFFERED YOU GUARANTEED FAME
IF YOU SLEPT WITH HIM,
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
April: IS HE ATTRACTIVE?
♪♪♪
Tyra: THEY'VE DONE
SOME VERY CREATIVE
AND AMAZING PHOTO SHOOTS.
ONE OF THE MOST CHALLENGING
WAS WHEN THE GIRLS
HAD TO IMPERSONATE CELEBRITIES.
Mercedes: OKAY,
I'M REALLY SICK.
I JUST FEEL
LIKE I'M GONNA FAINT.
I'M JUST REALLY TIRED,
BUT I'M TRYING TO HIDE IT.
Andrew: JUST SORT OF
CUP IT WITH YOUR HAND.
YEP, GOOD.
MERCEDES SEEMED NERVOUS.
I DETECTED THAT
SHE WAS EVEN SHAKING
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
Tyra: JUST...
(exhales)
Andrew: GOOD.
Tyra: THERE YOU GO.
Jay: MERCEDES,
IT'S JUST EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED.
- Tyra: YEAH.
- Andrew: NICE.
Mercedes: I PRAY
TO GOD EVERY TIME.
I ASK HIM TO PUT
A LITTLE "OOMPH" IN FOR ME.
Andrew: NICE.
♪♪♪
Jenascia: I THINK THEY
MIGHT HAVE PICKED SALMA FOR ME
BECAUSE SHE'S SHORT
AND I'M SHORT AND...
Tyra: NOW, JENASCIA,
THE LESS TEETH YOU SHOW,
THE MORE YOU LOOK LIKE
SALMA HAYEK.
Jenascia: DO THIS. DO THIS.
OH, OH, OH, OH.
Tyra: JENASCIA'S ATTITUDE
ON SET DIDN'T SCORE POINTS
WITH ANYONE.
Andrew: IT'S A 2-WAY STREET.
IT'S NOT FOR ME TO RUN
ALL THE WAY OVER THERE
AND GRAB EVERYTHING FROM YOU.
SHE PROBABLY HASN'T BEEN
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA
VERY OFTEN.
Tyra: WHEN J. ALEXANDER
SHOWED UP FOR
AN IMPROMPTU RUNWAY TUTORIAL,
JENASCIA SHOWED
MORE SHORTCOMINGS.
J.: MY PROBLEM WITH YOU
IS IT'S HERE.
THERE'S A VOICE SOMEWHERE
INSIDE THAT WE GOTTA BEAT
OUTTA HERE.
I NEED YOUR SHOULDERS LIKE THIS.
Jenascia: SO BASICALLY,
JUST STICK OUT MY BOOBS?
SO ALL I HAD TO DO
WAS STICK OUT MY BOOBS.
YOU COULDN'T HAVE TOLD ME THAT
THE FIRST DAY?
Tyra: THEN IT WAS TIME
FOR THE DELIBERATION.
Janice: SHE'S STILL TOO SHORT.
Tyra: I LIKE
THAT JENASCIA IS SHORT,
BUT, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU HAVE
THINGS THAT ARE LACKING
NEXT TO THE OTHER GIRLS,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOMETHING
EXTRA SPECIAL.
BUT JENASCIA WAS SENT HOME
AFTER NOT SHOWING THE JUDGES
ENOUGH OF THAT EXTRA EFFORT
SHE NEEDED
TO MAKE UP FOR HER HEIGHT.
Jenascia: THIS HOUSE IS
TOTALLY GONNA SUCK WITHOUT ME.
YOU SEE HOW I'M UPSET
BUT I CAN STILL BE FUNNY?
YOU SEE HOW I DO THAT?
I'M... GREAT.
(laughs)
Tyra: THE NEXT NIGHT,
AN INTUITIVE PSYCHIC VISITED
THE LOFT THE GIVE THE GIRLS
A READING.
Suzannah: MERCEDES,
YOUR BODY'S TIRED.
YOUR MIND ISN'T.
SOMETIMES YOU WANT TO DO MORE
THAN YOU PHYSICALLY CAN,
SO YOU'RE GONNA BE STRUGGLING.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT?
Mercedes: SHE'S DEAD ON,
AND SHE'S JUST DOING THIS
WITH NUMBERS, YOUR BIRTHDAY
AND YOUR NAME.
Sara: HOW DO YOU SEE MY FATHER
REACTING TO ME BEING A MODEL?
MY DAD IS HALF-IRANIAN,
AND HE CONSIDERS MODELING
PROSTITUTION.
Suzannah: HE'S GONNA HATE IT,
BUT HE'S GONNA SECRETLY LOVE IT.
Sara: REALLY?
Suzannah: MAKE PEACE WITH IT.
LET IT GO.
YOU'VE COME THIS FAR.
Tyra: YOANNA WAS LOOKING
FOR A CONNECTION
TO HER GRANDMOTHER.
Yoanna: SHE PASSED AWAY,
AND WE LOVED FASHION TOGETHER,
AND SHE'D WAKE ME UP
EVERY MORNING ON SATURDAYS
TO WATCH ELSA KLENSCH,
AND IF SHE KNEW I WAS HERE,
BECAUSE... (crying)
I WAS SO CHUBBY AND FAT
AND I ALWAYS GOT MADE FUN OF,
AND I LOST THE WEIGHT AND...
- Suzannah: YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL.
- Yoanna: AND, UM, I'M SORRY.
I JUST MISS HER SO MUCH.
Suzannah: BUT IT'S HERE
THAT SHE'LL ALWAYS BE WITH YOU.
YOU CAN'T KILL
A HEART CONNECTION EVER.
IT NEVER DIES.
Tyra: THE GIRLS'
INTERVIEW SKILLS WERE TESTED
BY THE BRUTALLY HONEST
JANICE DICKINSON.
Janice: IF A PHOTOGRAPHER
OFFERED YOU GUARANTEED FAME
IF YOU SLEPT WITH HIM
FOR A COVER OF A MAGAZINE
OR A MAKEUP CAMPAIGN,
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
April: IS HE ATTRACTIVE?
Yoanna: NO, THANK YOU. NEXT.
Camille: WAS HE FINE?
DID I LIKE HIM?
Sara: HELL, NO,
I WOULD NOT DO THAT.
April: I WOULDN'T NOT DO IT.
Janice: YOU SEEM TO BE
A LITTLE INTIMIDATED BY ME.
DO I MAKE YOU NERVOUS?
Camille: I LOVE YOU.
LIKE, PEOPLE MAY CALL YOU,
YOU KNOW,
"THE BITCH" OR WHATEVER--
Janice: THE BITCH?
I DIDN'T SAY "BITCH,"
BUT ARE THEY CALLING ME A BITCH?
Camille: PEOPLE MAY
CALL YOU THAT.
Janice: YOU KNOW,
THAT WAS REALLY OFFENSIVE TO ME.
YOU KNOW,
I'M A MEMBER OF THE P.T.A.
Tyra: AFTER BEING CONFRONTED
ABOUT HER LACK OF ENERGY,
MERCEDES HAD TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT TO COME CLEAN
ABOUT HER ILLNESS.
Mercedes: I'M LIKE,
"OH, MY GOSH.
"SHOULD I TELL HER I HAVE LUPUS?
AND I HAVEN'T
BEEN FEELING WELL
AND I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO HIDE IT?"
UM, I DON'T WANNA MAKE EXCUSES
THAT I HAVE AN ILLNESS,
BUT I DO.
UM, I HAVE LUPUS.
Janice: AND DOES THAT
PULL AWAY FROM YOUR ENERGY?
Mercedes: IT DOES.
I'M TRYING REALLY HARD
TO FIGHT THROUGH IT.
IT'S JUST SOMETIMES
I CAN'T CONTROL IT.
I MADE A HUGE DECISION.
I JUST SHARED A LITTLE PART
OF ME THAT I HAVE NEVER SHARED
WITH ANYBODY ELSE.
Janice: ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Tyra: MERCEDES WON
THE CONTEST AND PICKED SARA
TO SHARE HER PRIZE--
VISITS FROM THEIR MOMS.
Sara: OH, MY GOD!
(screaming)
Tyra: SARA STILL QUESTIONED
HER FATHER'S DISAPPROVAL
AND LOOKED TO HER MOM
FOR SUPPORT.
Sara's mom: IT'S HARD
TO SAY WITH YOUR DAD.
YOU HAVE NO CONTROL OVER WHAT HE
THINKS, SAYS OR ANYTHING, HONEY.
KNOW THAT IT'S CULTURAL.
Sara's mom: SARA, THEY LOVE YOU.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA HATE YOU.
Shandi: WATCHING,
YOU KNOW, MERCEDES AND SARA--
IT'S LIKE THEIR MOMS
KNOW THEM THROUGH AND THROUGH,
AND OF COURSE, IT MAKES ME SAD.
IT MAKES ME THINK ABOUT HOW
I'M NOT THAT WAY WITH MY MOM.
Tyra: THEN I BROUGHT
MY MOM TO THE LOFT
TO TALK ABOUT HOW SHE HELPED ME
GET STARTED IN MODELING.
Carolyn: SHE WOULD BEG ME,
"MOM, WOULD YOU TAKE
"SOME PICTURES OF ME?
I NEED SOME PICTURES
TO START A PORTFOLIO."
YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT I WAS DOING,
AND SHE
PRETTY MUCH DIDN'T EITHER.
BUT THE PHOTOS
CAME OUT REALLY GREAT.
(laughing)
SHE TOOK THOSE PHOTOGRAPHS
AND WENT AROUND
TO DIFFERENT AGENCIES.
Tyra: IN LOS ANGELES.
Carolyn: AND HOW MANY
SAID NO?
Tyra: SIX.
Carolyn: THE FIRST SIX
SAID NO.
Tyra: YEAH.
Carolyn: AND THEN ONE SAID YES.
Tyra: ON THAT JOURNEY,
YOUR MOMS HAVE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY TO KEEP YOU SANE
BECAUSE THIS BUSINESS IS INSANE.
Yoanna: YEAH.
Tyra: THE NEXT DAY
WAS A PHOTO SHOOT
IN A TANK OF SALT WATER.
♪♪♪
Tyra: WITH HER NEWFOUND
SELF-CONFIDENCE,
SARA NAILED THE SHOOT.
Jay: THE EYES
ARE TEN TIMES BETTER.
Nolé: THAT WAS--
THAT WAS GORGEOUS.
SHE LOOKS BLOATED,
LIKE A FISH.
IT'S GETTING DANGEROUS IN THERE.
THERE'S SOME SHARKS
IN THAT WATER.
♪♪♪
Jay: CAMILLE GOT IN THAT TANK,
AND I WAS
JUST EXPECTING AMAZING.
SHE GAVE ME KIND OF THIS,
LIKE, DRAG QUEEN VOGUE.
George: BEAUTIFUL. WOW.
GORGEOUS.
Nolé: SHE GAVE YOU
WATER COUTURE, HONEY.
Xiomara: IT'LL BE INTERESTING
TO SEE ME HOLDING MY BREATH
WITHOUT USING MY HANDS.
I'VE TRIED IT, AND WATER
GOES ALL UP IN MY NOSE.
Tyra: XIOMARA HAD
A GORGEOUS, EXOTIC FACE,
BUT IN THE MODELING INDUSTRY,
IT'S NOT ABOUT
HOW PRETTY YOU ARE.
IT'S HOW YOU HANDLE
YOUR PHOTO SHOOTS.
Jay: YOUR EYES ARE CLOSED
IN EVERY SHOT.
Nolé: XIOMARA--
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS GIRL.
SHE LOOKED LIKE A WALRUS
WEARING CHIFFON.
IT WAS A DISASTER
FROM START TO FINISH.
Tyra: AND AT
THE NEXT ELIMINATION,
IT CAME DOWN TO CAMILLE
AND XIOMARA.
Nolé: XIOMARA--SHE LOOKED
LIKE SHE WAS FLOUNDERING,
LIKE A LARGE ANIMAL
IN THE WATER.
IT WAS VERY UNATTRACTIVE.
I THINK XIOMARA IS
ONE OF THE FEW GIRLS
WHO COULD BE DOING
THE COUTURE RUNWAYS IN PARIS.
- Nigel: ERIC.
- Nolé: WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU?
Eric: I THINK
THAT THERE'S POTENTIAL IN THAT.
Tyra: AND IN THE END,
XIOMARA WAS SENT HOME.
Xiomara: OF COURSE
I WANNA STAY HERE.
I DON'T WANNA GO.
I WANNA STAY.
BUT, UM, YOU KNOW,
IF I'M NOT WHAT SOMEONE WANTS,
I'M COOL WITH THAT.
LIKE, I'M NOT GONNA SIT HERE
AND BEAT MYSELF UP BECAUSE
I'M NOT WHAT SOMEONE WANTS.
Tyra: AFTER SURVIVING
NEAR ELIMINATION,
CAMILLE WAS MORE DETERMINED
THAN EVER TO SHOW THE JUDGES
HER STAR POWER.
Camille: SALUD.
Tyra: BUT ON THE MORNING
OF THEIR NEXT PHOTO SHOOT,
CAMILLE AWOKE
WITH A BIG PROBLEM.
SHE'D HAD AN ALLERGIC REACTION,
AND HER LIPS WERE SWOLLEN.
Camille: BUT IT'S JUST
GETTING WORSE.
LIKE, IT'S JUST GETTING TIGHTER.
Tyra: AS THE GIRLS POSED,
CAMILLE HOPED HER LIPS
WOULD HEAL.
- Mercedes: LET ME SEE.
- Camille: I JUST CAN FEEL IT.
Mercedes: I JUST CAN'T
REMEMBER HOW BIG YOUR LIPS
WERE TO BEGIN WITH.
Tyra: EVEN THOUGH CAMILLE
WAS THE ONE WITH THE CRISIS,
WHEN IT CAME TO ACTING CLASS,
SHE WAS THE ONLY ONE
TO HOLD BACK HER EMOTIONS.
Sara: I'M DOING THIS
BECAUSE IF YOU DISOWN ME--
I'M GONNA BE A MODEL.
YOU CAN HATE ME.
Shandi: I DON'T KNOW
ANYONE IN MY FAMILY
BECAUSE OF YOU.
April: YOU'RE--YOU'RE...
Women: (sobbing)
Camille: OH... MY... GOD.
Tyra: IN A LATER EXERCISE,
CAMILLE NOT ONLY REFUSED
TO SHOW EMOTION,
SHE ALSO REWROTE THE SCRIPT.
Camille: I DIDN'T BELIEVE IT,
WHAT THEY TOLD ME.
IT'S TRUE. YOU ARE ALIVE.
Mark: HOW LONG HAS IT BEEN?
Camille: NOT ONE,
NOT TWO, BUT THREE LONG MONTHS.
I CRIED, COLIN,
NOT FOR ONE, NOT FOR TWO,
BUT I CRIED FOR SIX MONTHS.
YOU KNOW ME, LAURA,
STRONG, PROUD,
THE ONE THAT YOU
LOVED AND RESPECTED.
I FOCUSED MY ENERGY
INTO SCULPTING.
I EVEN GAVE
SOME AWAY TO CHARITY.
WHY DID YOU HAVE TO LEAVE ME,
BABY?
Tasha: I DIDN'T BELIEVE
ANYTHING YOU DID UP THERE--
NOTHING.
I THOUGHT IT WAS HORRIBLE.
(sighs) POOR CAMILLE.
SHE'S CLUELESS.
Tyra: NOW CAMILLE WASN'T
THE ONLY GIRL HAVING PROBLEMS
WITH ACTING.
Catie: WHEN THEY TOLD ME
YOUR PLANE WENT DOWN
IN THE JUNGLE...
AND THERE WERE NO SURVIVORS,
I DIDN'T SHED A TEAR.
- Mark: (suppresses chuckle)
- Catie: I'M HALF-ASSING IT.
HOW THE CRAP
CAN I TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY?
Tasha: YOU COULD'VE
KISSED HIM BETTER THAN THAT.
Catie: I CAN'T,
I HAVE A BOYFRIEND.
Tasha: SO WHAT?
THIS IS ABOUT WINNING.
YOU HAVE TO STAY COMMITTED
IN THE SCENE.
I DON'T CARE
ABOUT YOUR BOYFRIEND.
♪ THE FUTURE IS NOW ♪
Tyra: THEN IT WAS TIME
FOR THE GIRLS TO PUT
THEIR NEW ACTING SKILLS
ON THE LINE WHEN THEY SHOT
A HIGH ACTION COMMERCIAL.
Mercedes: AND THERE'S ONLY--
WHAT? (giggles)
Yoanna: THERE WILL ONLY BE
ONE CHOICE.
Camille: (British accent)
FOR AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Catie: JUST ONE.
Sara: UNO, BABY.
Shandi: SO YOU GOTTA BE TOUGH.
Mercedes: HEY,
A GIRL'S GOTTA DO
WHAT A GIRL'S GOTTA DO.
Jay: TOUGH SUPERHERO,
NOT TOUGH BRONX.
James: YEAH.
Mercedes: I'M FROM JERSEY.
- Sara: (roars)
- Catie: (roars)
- Yoanna: (roars)
- Mercedes: (roars)
James: OKAY. OH, NO.
TOO CUTE.
Mercedes: I'M TOO CUTE.
Tyra: AT THE ELIMINATION,
CATIE'S MATURITY AND COMMITMENT
WERE QUESTIONED.
Nigel: IT'S AMAZING
HOW YOUNG--YOU REALLY SEE
- THAT YOU'RE 18 YEARS OLD.
- Janice: YOU LOOK 13.
REALLY, REALLY YOUNG,
LIKE CHILD PROSTITUTE.
Eric: SHE'S KIND OF
THE GIRL NEXT DOOR.
Janice: EW.
Eric: BUT I THINK
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
HAS TO BE, LIKE, THE GIRL, LIKE,
WAY OVER THERE.
Tyra: DOWN THE STREET,
AROUND THE CORNER.
Eric: YEAH. EXACTLY.
Tyra: CATIE WAS SENT HOME.
Catie: THANKS, GUYS.
(sobbing)
I DON'T FEEL REJECTED.
GO BACK TO L.A.,
WORK MY ASS OFF
AND GET TO THE TOP ON MY OWN.
♪♪♪
Tyra: STILL TO COME--
THE GIRLS LEARN
SOME NEW MOVES...
Kevin: THAT'S A DIVA, HONEY.
Tony: YOU ARE ILLEGAL.
Tyra: AND THE RESULTS
AREN'T ALWAYS PRETTY.
Janice: WHAT THE HELL
WAS THAT?
♪♪♪
Tyra: A TOP MODEL
HAS TO MOVE GRACEFULLY
ON THE RUNWAY,
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
AT PUBLIC APPEARANCES,
EVERYWHERE.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT THAT A MODEL
BE ABLE TO EXPRESS HERSELF
THROUGH HER BODY.
SO I PUT THE GIRLS IN THE HANDS
OF CHOREOGRAPHER TONY MICHAELS,
WHO TRIED TO
TEACH THEM SOME MOVES.
♪ WHOA ♪
♪ WHOA... ♪
Camille: CAN I USE A CHAIR?
Tony: NO.
YOU CAN'T USE NO CHAIR.
Yoanna: IMAGINE, IMAGINE--
CAMILLE, CAMILLE,
ALWAYS HAVE TO UP AND UP.
♪ WHOA... ♪♪
Tony: GIRL,
GO ON OVER THERE.
GO ON OVER THERE,
'CAUSE YOU ARE ILLEGAL!
Tyra: THAT NIGHT,
THE GIRLS WERE GIVEN
A LITTLE LESSON
IN RUNWAY STYLE
BY SOME OF NEW YORK CITY'S
MOST DIVA-LICIOUS DRAG QUEENS.
LET'S PARTY!
♪♪♪
Tyra: IT IS IMPOSSIBLE
TO IGNORE A DRAG QUEEN
ON THE RUNWAY,
AND I WANTED TO INSPIRE
THE GIRLS IN THE WAY
THAT THEY MOVE, DANCE,
AND JUST PLAIN WORK IT.
Kevin: LOOK AT THEM.
LOOK AT
THEIR FACIAL EXPRESSIONS.
LOOK AT THEIR EYES.
LOOK AT THE WAY
THEY'RE USING THEIR SHOULDERS.
DO YOU SEE HOW SHE WALKED ON?
DID YOU SEE THAT?
THAT'S A DIVA, HONEY.
DID YOU SEE THE WAY
SHE WALKED ON?
NOW IT'S YOUR TURN.
Tyra: GET UP!
♪♪♪
Tyra: ♪ GO, APRIL ♪
♪ GO, APRIL ♪
♪ GO, SHANDI, GO, SHANDI ♪
♪ GO, MERCEDES, WORK IT OUT ♪♪
Tyra: WHOO! WORK IT OUT!
All: ♪ GO, TYRA, GO, TY ♪
♪ GO, TYRA ♪♪
Kevin: TYRA'S WALK
IS LIKE A SYMPHONY.
IT'S LIKE HAIR, CHEST,
ASS, LEGS.
IT'S, LIKE, MUSIC.
Tyra: AWAY FROM HOME,
SHANDI FOUND IT HARD
TO TRUST HER BOYFRIEND.
Eric: And I'm gonna go
see a movie tonight.
I'm going with Lauren.
Shandi: OH, THAT'S GREAT.
Eric: (laughing)
Honey, she has a kid
and a husband!
Shandi: OH, SO, UM,
PEOPLE NEVER CHEAT
ON THEIR HUSBANDS?
Eric: No, they don't!
Shandi: YES, THEY DO.
Eric: I can't go
to the movies now?
Shandi: NO! I HATE YOU.
Eric: I didn't--
I didn't know that!
You didn't say that.
You didn't say don't--
Shandi: I SHOULDN'T HAVE
TO SAY THAT.
♪♪♪
Tyra: EVERY ONE OF THE GIRLS
CAME TO PURSUE THEIR DREAMS,
AND I WANTED THEM TO SHARE
MY DREAMS, TOO.
I ACTUALLY GOT TO FILM
THE MUSIC VIDEO
FROM MY VERY FIRST SINGLE HERE
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
I GOT TO HAVE MY GIRLS
BE IN THE VIDEO WITH ME.
THAT WAS AN ABSOLUTELY AMAZING
EXPERIENCE.
NICE.
- (laughter)
- Man: PLAYBACK, PLEASE.
Tyra: ♪ CAN'T FIGURE OUT
WHY Y'ALL SAID IT'S OVER... ♪
AT THE VIDEO SHOOT, THE GIRLS
GOT TO PUT TONY'S CHOREOGRAPHY
TO USE.
♪ AND THE RATIO'S
GOOD ENOUGH FOR US ♪
♪ AND I SEE ONE
POSSIBLY FOR ME ♪
♪ SO COME AND TELL ME
WHAT'S GOOD WITH YOU, PLAYA ♪
♪ I'M FEELIN' YOU
ARE YOU FEELIN' ME, PLAYA? ♪
♪ 'CAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
I DON'T PLAY, I ♪
♪ SHAKE YA BODY, BODY,
MOVE YA BODY, BODY... ♪
Shandi: YOANNA JUST FALLS
FLAT ON THE FLOOR.
(laughing)
Yoanna: IN THE END
WHAT TRIPPED ME UP
IS NOT FINDING THE RIGHT BEAT
OR THE COUNT TO THE MUSIC.
Tyra: ♪ I'M TRYIN' TO
FREAK YOU ON THE FLOOR ♪
♪ LET ME SEE,
DON'T STOP, SHAKE YA BODY ♪
♪ TILL IT'S SORE ♪
♪♪♪
Tyra: AT THE SEVENTH
ELIMINATION,
WE ASKED THE GIRLS TO DANCE
FOR US FREESTYLE
AND GOT SOME PRETTY
UNUSUAL RESULTS.
♪♪♪
Janice: WHAT THE HELL
WAS THAT?
Tyra: IN THE END,
SARA AND YOANNA
FACED ELIMINATION.
THIS IS THE HARDEST WEEK FOR ME,
AND IT'S HARD FOR ME BECAUSE
(voice breaking) I'M STARTING
SOMETHING NEW IN MY LIFE--
SOMETHING THAT
I'M PUTTING MYSELF OUT THERE
FOR THE WORLD TO PUT ME
IN THE POSITION
THAT YOU ALL ARE IN NOW.
SO WHO AM I TO STAND HERE
AND TELL YOU THAT YOU HAVE
TO LEAVE WHEN I'M STARTING
SOMETHING WHERE THE WHOLE WORLD
IS GONNA BE CRITICIZING ME?
YOANNA, CONGRATULATIONS.
Sara: (sobbing)
Sara: I'M SO PROUD OF MYSELF.
I'VE DONE THINGS THAT I'VE
NEVER EVEN IMAGINED ME DOING
IN MY LIFE--
THINGS I'VE BEEN SCARED TO DO,
THINGS THAT I HAD TO BREAK OUT
OF MY SHELL TO DO,
AND THIS MADE ME DO THAT.
♪♪♪
Tyra: WITH FEWER GIRLS LEFT,
SOME SURPRISING ALLIANCES
WERE FORMED.
April: I, LIKE, DON'T KNOW
WHEN IT HAPPENED,
BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN,
YOANNA AND CAMILLE
ARE, LIKE, FRIENDS.
Yoanna: EBONY AND IVORY'S
FIRST CONFESSIONAL TOGETHER.
OH, MY.
WELL, HELLO, MISS DIANA ROSS,
YOU'VE ARRIVED.
NOW HOW ARE YOU
TAKING THIS CITY?
IS THIS SPACE ENOUGH ROOM
FOR YOU?
Camille: OH,
ARE YOU TALKING TO ME?
I'M SO SORRY.
YOANNA, I LOVE YOU.
GIVE ME SOME LOVE!
Yoanna: (laughing)
Camille: DON'T EVER GIVE ME
THE FINGER AGAIN, OKAY?
Yoanna: SOME DAYS
I LOVE YOU, TOO.
Tyra: TOP MODELS ARE CALLED
UPON TO DO ALL SORTS OF THINGS.
LUCKILY, ONE THING THEY DON'T
HAVE TO DO IS RAP FREESTYLE.
Yoanna: ♪ I THINK IT MIGHT
BE SOMETHING THAT WE MIGHT ♪
♪ BE GOING SOMEWHERE
HAD A DREAM WE WOULD BE ♪
♪ FLYIN' ON A PLANE ♪♪
Mercedes: ♪ A PLANE TO ♪
♪ MM, I DON'T KNOW
BUT WE'RE IN LITTLE ITALY ♪
♪ MAYBE IT'S... IN SOHO ♪♪
(laughter)
April: ♪ WOKE UP THIS MORNIN' ♪
♪ I THOUGHT TO MYSELF
I THINK ALL OF US ♪
♪ ARE GONNA BE TAKING
A NICE TRIP ♪♪
Camille: ♪ PACK YOUR BAGS,
DON'T BE MAD ♪
♪ WE'RE ALL FLYING IN
AND TRAVELING ♪
♪ BE SURE YOU GOT
YOUR TRAVEL-SIZE MAKEUP ♪♪
Shandi: ♪ ALL SITTIN' HERE
HAVING FUN WITH EACH OTHER ♪
♪ I WANTED Y'ALL TO KNOW
THAT I AIN'T YOUR BROTHER ♪♪
(laughter)
Tyra: ♪ TOP MODELS ♪
♪ PACK QUICK
ON THE ROAD, ALWAYS GONE ♪
♪ PACK YOUR BAGS, Y'ALL
YOU'RE GOING TO MILAN! ♪♪
Women: (screaming)
♪♪♪
Tyra: ONCE THEY HIT
THE GROUND, THE GIRLS WERE
SENT OUT ON AUDITIONS,
OR AS THEY ARE KNOWN IN
THE FASHION INDUSTRY, GO-SEES.
Michael: (Italian accent)
OKAY, SHE WANTS TO KNOW WHY
YOU WALK LIKE THIS, EXPLAIN.
EXPLAIN. TRY TO EXPLAIN.
Camille: THIS IS
MY SIGNATURE WALK, AND THIS IS
WHAT'S GOING TO MAKE ME FAMOUS.
Michael: DO YOU HAVE
EXPERIENCE? NO, OKAY.
- Liliana: BYE.
- Michael: OKAY, GO.
Shandi: SHE'S A MEANIE,
AND SHE IS A BAD WOMAN,
AND I DON'T LIKE HER.
Camille: I'VE MET WORSE.
Tyra: YOANNA, THEY SAID THAT
YOU HAD A REALLY GORGEOUS FACE,
BUT THEY AREN'T SO SURE
YOU HAVE A BODY
FOR HIGH FASHION.
Yoanna: DO THEY MEAN, LIKE,
TONING OR...
Tyra: PROBABLY. YEAH.
Yoanna: BECAUSE I'M ALREADY
A SIZE 2, I MEAN...
Tyra: THE HARSH CRITICISM
REALLY GOT TO YOANNA,
WHO LOST OVER 40 POUNDS
JUST A YEAR
BEFORE THE COMPETITION.
Yoanna: (sniffling)
Yoanna: I'M UPSET BECAUSE
THE CLIENTS SAID THAT I
PROBABLY DON'T HAVE THE BODY
TO BE A TOP MODEL.
Tyra: AFTER
A GOOD NIGHT'S SLEEP,
YOANNA WAS BACK IN THE GAME
AT A HAUTE COUTURE
FASHION SHOOT.
Massimo: GOOD.
Yoanna: I FEEL LIKE
I AM LIVING THE TEEN DREAM.
I AM WEARING HAUTE COUTURE.
WHAT MORE CAN A GIRL ASK FOR?
Massimo: BRAVA. BELLA COS.
NICE.
STAY LIKE THIS. STAY.
DON'T CLOSE YOUR EYES.
I DON'T LIKE TO FORCE IT.
Jay: IF YOU'RE GONNA DO THIS,
IT DOESN'T--
IT NEEDS TO MEAN SOMETHING.
CAMILLE OVERTHINKS HER POSES.
SHE JUST NEVER LETS GO.
Yoanna: WHO'D HAVE EVER
THOUGHT EBONY AND IVORY WOULD BE
SHARING A ROOM TOGETHER?
CAMILLE AND I ARE GETTING ALONG
A LOT MORE SO
THAN IN THE BEGINNING,
I WANNA KEEP PEACE.
Camille: THE BEST WAY
TO SEEK REVENGE ON SOMEONE
IS TO KILL 'EM WITH KINDNESS,
SO THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING.
I'M KILLING YOANNA
WITH KINDNESS.
Tyra: AN ITALIAN DINNER
REVEALED MORE TO
THE CAMILLE/YOANNA FRIENDSHIP
THAN MET THE EYE.
Jay: DOES SHE ALWAYS
DISAPPEAR TO THE BATHROOM
AFTER DINNER?
- Mercedes: NO.
- April: NO.
Camille: SHE, YOU KNOW,
DISAPPEARS AND...
Tyra: AFTER EVERY MEAL?
Tyra: WELL, THE EATING DISORDER
THING IS VERY SENSITIVE TO ME.
JUST KEEP AN EYE ON THAT,
YOU KNOW?
IF YOU CAN WATCH HER FOR ME.
Mercedes: IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WHAT GETS SAID
AT THAT TABLE WHEN TYRA IS THERE
IS THE TRUTH
AND NOTHING BUT THE TRUTH.
YOU KNOW, CAMILLE INSINUATED
THAT YOANNA HAS
AN EATING DISORDER,
WHICH IS NOT TRUE.
CAMILLE, YOU WERE SITTING HERE
LIKE THIS, AND JAY SAID.
AND YOU WERE LIKE THIS.
Camille: NO, HE DIDN'T SAY,
"DOES SHE HAVE
AN EATING DISORDER?"
SHE SAID,
"DOES SHE DISAPPEAR A LOT?"
Mercedes: RIGHT. HELLO,
OBVIOUSLY, THE UNDERLYING THING
IS THAT SHE HAS
AN EATING DISORDER. DUH.
Camille: THE QUESTION WAS IF
SHE DISAPPEARS A LOT, AND YES,
SHE DOES DISAPPEAR A LOT.
Yoanna: CAMILLE,
DO YOU UNDERSTAND
THIS IS A MODELING THING,
AND FOR SOMEONE TO COME OUT
AND SAY THAT YOANNA MIGHT HAVE
AN EATING DISORDER--
- Camille: I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
- Yoanna: OR HAVE IT INFERRED.
Mercedes: SHE DIDN'T SAY IT.
Yoanna: WHAT DID YOU
JUST SAY?
Camille: AND I WAS JUST LIKE...
Tyra: YOU REALLY NEED TO
STAND UP FOR YOURSELF.
MY MOM CALLS IT THE UGLY SIDE OF
THE BEAUTIFUL MODELING INDUSTRY.
AT THE JUDGING,
THE GIRLS WERE EVALUATED
ON HIDDEN CAMERA FOOTAGE
OF THEIR GO-SEES.
Michael: (American accent)
OKAY, GIRL,
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR CLIP.
Janice: THIS I GOTTA SEE.
Michael: (Italian accent)
OKAY, SHE WANTS TO KNOW
WHY YOU WALK LIKE THIS.
Camille: THIS IS
MY SIGNATURE WALK, AND THIS IS
WHAT'S GOING TO MAKE ME FAMOUS.
ACTUALLY, I'M HERE BECAUSE
I GOT CHOSEN OUT OF 6,000 GIRLS
AND 12 WERE CHOSEN FOR
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
- Eric: (groaning)
- Janice: CAMILLE,
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
Tyra: CAMILLE'S
OVERBEARING ARROGANCE
TURNED THE JUDGES OFF,
AND SHE WAS SENT PACKING.
Camille: CIAO.
IT'S ALL GOOD,
BECAUSE DEEP DOWN IN MY HEART,
I KNOW WHO CAMILLE IS,
AND PEOPLE CAN TELL ME
TO CHANGE, CHANGE, CHANGE
ALL DAY LONG,
AND I JUST GOTTA--
I GOTTA BE ME.
♪♪♪
Tyra: NOW FOUR GIRLS REMAIN--
THE NERDY WALGREENS CLERK,
THE SLIMMED-DOWN
FASHION FANATIC,
THE ANALYTICAL BUSINESSWOMAN
AND THE SPUNKY SPITFIRE.
TUNE IN NEXT WEEK TO SEE
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED NEXT.
♪♪♪
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
A VISIT FROM SOME
LOCAL ITALIAN MEN
LEADS TO A DEVASTATING CRISIS
FOR SHANDI.
April: SHE'S FEELING
EXTREME GUILT.
Shandi: I WANNA DIE.
I JUST LET IT HAPPEN.
Eric: You had sex?!
Oh, my God.
Shandi: I'M SORRY, HONEY.
Eric: (shrieking)
What were you thinking?!
Shandi: I JUST WANNA GO HOME.
(giggling)
woman: YOU SHUT UP.
♪♪♪